alright the left's attempt to shut down
and just demonize conservatives in this
country is ramping up again this time
they're attacking African American
conservative commentator Candace Owens
for taking on black lives matter
protesters during an event at UCLA
take a look what is happening right now
in the black community you're gonna hear
in this room first there's a an
ideological civil war happening black
you letter focus on their past and
shouting about slavery and by people
that are focused on their futures victim
mentality is not cool I don't know why
people like being oppressed so weirdest
thing I've ever heard I love oppression
we're oppressed 400 years of slavery Jim
Crow which by the way none of you guys
live do your grandparents didn't it's
embarrassing that you utilize you
utilize their history you utilize their
history and you come in here with more
emotion than ever have when they were
living through it more emotion than they
ever had when they were living through
it it's embarrassing you're not living
through anything right now you're overly
privileged American and on Saturday
Kanye West praised Owens on Twitter and
he wrote this quote I love the way
Candace Owens thinks but not every one
of Owens is a fan with compliments and
support Kanye West support look what Tom
Arnold went on a sexist brutal vicious
hateful racist tirade on Twitter here's
just some of what he tweeted aside from
being an insane all right raised pimp
Candice owns things Donald Trump is
literally the Messiah not you at Kanye
West so you might want to reconsider you
also wrote at real Kondos good luck
while glomming on to Kanye West his
family already told him you were a phony
and a fraud a former democratic bad
actors but I didn't want to talk about
this anymore Candace now joins us here
you are a total star I watched that tape
I am so impressed and so happy for you
that you have this gift but I am so sad
for you also that you have to take on
those vicious attacks like that thank
you so much first of all for the
compliment it means a lot coming from
you and let me tell you do not be sad
for me this is exactly what I wanted
this is exactly what I intended to
happen because I knew exactly what I was
going up against when you go up against
the
this is what they do they try to
essentially say that you are not allowed
to think differently I say it all the
time
blacks are ideological slaves and pawns
to the Democratic Party try it and
invest in real estate if you don't put
your money on them under a mattress
believe me I know what you mean it's not
the same though how I watch Kanye West I
was so happy that he did that because
that's what I always thought everybody
should embrace this freedom why do so
many have a problem with this it's not a
problem with that you have to think
about what the left has done
successfully they've hijacked our
education they hijacked our families via
LBJ and the Great Society act taking
away black fathers so that black youth
would start to look at hip-hop culture
and an NBA and ass NFL athletes for the
right direction this is why they are
constantly utilizing Hollywood and their
zobelle this underground system of
conservative thinkers in Hollywood for
fear of losing their jobs Connie was
just the first person that's brave
enough to come out swinging against them
and saying that he has a right to think
according to how he would like to I I
really thought honestly it was so
refreshing that he did that and I was I
was happy for you you know a very dear
friend of mine didn't even Borelli she's
been the guest on this program often she
wrote a best-selling book blacklash the
first thing she writes in the book is
google my name and because she happens
to be a black American who is
conservative the things that come up are
the most vicious why why do you think
that is well I think that the reason is
because politics is downstream from
culture and if they lose the culture war
they lose absolutely everything they
have they cannot afford to have black
people thinking differently if we move
the black vote even 5% the democratic
party is absolutely finished so it's
essentially a house of cards they've
been building when you get black icons
by Kanye West you get oh I'm sorry go
finish your client no finish line or you
get black stars to speak out against
them they're in serious trouble look at
under President Trump black and Hispanic
unemployment is at the lowest level it's
ever been at 14 states have record low
unemployment numbers
after eight years of President Obama 13
million more Americans were on food
stamps eight million more in poverty I
said that every night do you think this
is going to change because the Democrats
those every year every election year
they play the race card Republicans
don't want to count you in the census
the James Byrd ad and so on and so forth
do you think this changes is there a
cultural shift based on results coming
100 percent there's going to be a
cultural shift and you mentioned the
black caucus which stood for more food
stamps when Obama announced it but sat
when Trump announced black unemployment
that is disgusting okay and that is
because they work for leftist and it's
been infected it is a swamp and I'm
telling you right now we are on the
brink of an ideological revolution and
the black community is going to start
waking up and I'm so happy that I get to
play a part in this I gotta tell you I
admire you so much you are a force of
light and a star and I am going to
really enjoy watching your career
trajectory just soar and I wish you all
God's grace and success in the future
thank you so much for being with us and
thanks Thank You Kayne of what he did
for you - thank you so much